et
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo nous
sommes à bruxelles au coeur du parlement
européen et l'actualité de la semaine ce
sont les paradis fiscaux l'europe en
compte une demi douzaine en son sein
comment lutter contre l'évasion fiscale
c'est ce que tente de faire les
responsables européens l'événement c'est
aussi le décès de margaret thatcher
l'ancien premier ministre britannique a
marqué l'histoire européenne florilège
des télévisions d'europe
la vérité c'est que margaret thatcher
n'a pas seulement dirigé notre pays
elle l'a sauvée et elle restera comme le
plus grand premier ministre de
l'histoire moderne de la grande bretagne
j'ai été profondément attristé
d'entendre les nouvelles de la mort de
la baronne thatcher
elle était sans aucun doute une grande
femme d'état la première femme premier
ministre dans son pays est une actrice
circonspecte mais engagée dans l'union
européenne
le président de la commission monsieur
de l'or a dit l'autre jour qu'il voulait
que le parlement européen soit le corps
démocratique de la communauté que la
commission soit l'exécutif et que le
conseil des ministres soit le sénat sur
le plan européen la dame de fer qu'on
soit l'europe comme un outil pour
accélérer le libre échange et garantir
la concurrence elle refuse toute idée de
super état européen et exige de la cee
d'alors le célèbre chef d'un milliard de
livres sterling pour la contribution
britannique
elle obtiendra sa restitution en 1984 il
n'y a pas de demi-mesure lorsque l'on
parle de mariage satcher elle était la
plus aimée mais aussi la plus détestée
la femme la plus influente du pays
cholet est la plus caricaturer aussi je
voudrais insister quelques hui son cru
cette semaine nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir quentin dickinson bonjour
bonjour vous êtes chef du bureau
européen à bruxelles de radio france
vous êtes le grand spécialiste des
questions européennes vous connaissez
tous des arcanes de la politique
européenne
alors les six thatcher était connu en
europe pour ce nom sont intransigeants
son opposition dans les débats européens
notamment sur le budget européen avec ce
rabais britannique qu'elle a contribué à
obtenir pour son pays de haute lutte
quelques l image qu est ce qu elle
incarnait pour vous eh bien les milieux
européens dont je fais par la bande
partie retiennent de madame thatcher
l'image une personne intransigeante
agaçante horripilante très souvent
quelqu'un qui était extrêmement sûre
d'elle-même qui intervenait à tout bout
de champ qui poussait à bout ses
adversaires c'est partenaires et qui au
fond n'a jamais eu beaucoup de
considération pour ceux ci elle pensait
qu'elle était investi d'un pouvoir
absolu qu'elle représentait à elle même
toute la force toutes les vertus tous
les intérêts des peuples du royaume uni
et de ce point de vue là elle obtenait
le plus souvent gain de cause
elle poussait les gens dans leurs
retranchements et les avait à l'usure et
pourtant et pourtant en face d'elle elle
avait des adversaires ou les partenaires
selon qu'ils étaient de poids excusez du
peu pour la france giscard pour
l'allemagne helmut schmidt et pourtant
ces deux là il les a roulés dans la
farine et les reparti vous lui disiez
avec son rabais sur la contribution
britannique au budget communautaire un
rabais qui déjà à l'époque ne se
justifiaient de façon comptable pas
vraiment et aujourd'hui les britanniques
essaie de nous faire croire que c'est un
acquis perpétuelle ce ne doit pas l'être
est-ce qu'elle était fondamentalement
européenne est ce qu elle a quand même
apporté quelque chose
un construction européenne ou pas et
leur apporter ce qu'elle souhaitait en
retirer en réalité pour les britanniques
du temps de madame thatcher est encore
dans une grande mesure aujourd'hui
l'union européenne la construction
européenne c'est très secondaire c'est
un marché un supermarché où vient faire
ses emplettes on pense qu'on veut et on
laisse le reste donc madame thatcher a
effectivement contribué
madame thatcher voulait ce grand marché
européen qui existe aujourd'hui qui se
parent fait encore de nos jours et pour
ce faire c'est avec enthousiasme qu'elle
a apposé sa signature au bas de l'acte
unique européen
pourtant voulue par le socialiste
français jacques delors qui présidait la
commission à l'époque donc il s'agissait
de bénéficier d'un marché vers lequel
les produits britanniques pouvaient
s'exporter de même madame thatcher a
toujours beaucoup soutenu l'idée de
l'élargissement de l'union européenne au
plus grand nombre possible de pays
membres pourquoi parce qu'elle savait
très bien que l'élargissement
c'était quelque chose qui freina qui tua
éventuellement l'approfondissement et
donc la partie politique de la
construction européenne et la rejeter
entièrement est ce que aujourd'hui les
choses ont vraiment changé pour la
grande bretagne est ce que la politique
menée actuellement par le conservateur
cameron est différente est
fondamentalement différente de celle de
maria thatcher en 1979 quand il était
entré au 10 downing street madame
thatcher et tient la tête d'un pays qui
étaient en grand déclin économique est
désemparé du point de vue social elle a
fait quelque chose et la rebâtir une
nation
l'expédition malouines n'est pas pour
rien dans le regain de fierté nationale
des britanniques
mais aujourd'hui la grande bretagne et
sur un déclin nouveau le pétrole et le
gaz de la mer du nord ne sont pas
éternels il y a des schismes intérieur
il ya ce fameux référendum sur
l'indépendance écossaise donc l'horizon
est couvert de brouillard une fois de
plus au royaume uni et ce royaume uni là
effectivement se pose aujourd'hui des
questions avec à sa tête quelqu'un qui
n'est pas l'héritier véritablement de
margaret thatcher
magath sall cheikh avait cette
intelligence de la situation dans une
négociation de faire en sorte qu'elle
laissait toujours planer une espèce de
menaces très vague mais jamais elle ne
se serait permise c'était une faiblesse
effectivement de dire c'est ça où nous
quittons l'union européenne jamais elle
ne l'a dit et c'est le piège dans lequel
david cameron son successeur s'est
enfermé alors elle est aussi connue pour
ses phrases son ton péremptoire certains
actions notamment celui ci deyris no
alternative
il n'y a pas d'alternative c'est valable
aussi notamment pour la politique
économique qu'elle a mené mais
aujourd'hui on a l'impression d'entendre
aussi ce discours canton quand on entend
certains dirigeants européens justifier
la nécessité de mener des politiques de
rigueur
est ce que ce n'est pas ce discours là
aussi qui domine aujourd'hui le il n'y a
pas d'alternative
cette sorte de pensée unique économique
c'est la même partition mais je n'ai pas
le même interprète et les interprètes
actuels n'ont pas le talent le madame
thatcher et bien merci
ce sera le mot de la fin et on va parler
à présent merci quentin dickinson on va
parler à présent de la situation
politique en italie
très compliqué puisque le pays n'a
toujours pas de gouvernement
on en parle avec un journaliste italien
lorenzo consoli vais d'abord cette
question l'italie est-elle ingouvernable
25 février la gauche de pier luigi
bersani arrive en tête des élections
générales italienne devant le parti de
silvio berlusconi
le leader démocrate obtient la majorité
à la chambre des députés mais pas au
sénat en raison de règles électorales
complexes et c'est un nouveau venu le
mouvement cinq étoiles de l'ancien
comique beppe grillo qui créait la
surprise de ce scrutin
arrivé à la troisième place la formation
se définit par son rejet du système
politique et des partis traditionnels
problème les trois forces politiques
sont incapables de se mettre d'accord
pour former un gouvernement silvio
berlusconi refuse de faire alliance avec
les centristes de mario monti dont la
coalition fait moins de 10%
beppe grillo refuse de négocier avec les
autres formations
résultat un mois plus tard père luigi
bersani jette l'épongé
à ce stade tout simplement le président
de la république a décidé de conduire
directement ses propres consultations
c'est tout pour débloquer la situation
le président de la république giorgio
napolitano a une idée il charge un
groupe d'experts de trouver une solution
à cette crise composé de personnalités
de tous bords ce collège a une double
mission réformer la loi électorale
à l'origine de l'impasse et proposer des
mesures pour faire repartir l'économie
italienne en récession depuis un an et
demi six semaines après les élections
législatives
le pays n'a toujours pas de gouvernement
alors l'italie est-elle ingouvernable
alors pour tenter de comprendre cette
situation très compliquée un journaliste
italien est avec nous lorenzo consoli
bonjour alors vous écrivait notamment
pour l' agence de presse italienne tm
news et vous êtes un grand spécialiste
des questions européennes
expliquez-nous ce qui se passe en fait
est ce que votre pays aujourd'hui est
ingouvernable et quelle est l'issue non
je ne crois pas que l'italie soit sont
ingouvernables le problème que on s'est
retrouvé avec une loi électorale qui
était fait pour ne pas permettre au
parti qui a gagné les élections les
partis démocrates centre gauche de
pouvoir gouverner puisque même s'il a la
majorité dans la chambre des députés
le système électoral électorale est
telle que dans le sénat le parti n'a pas
de la majorité et donc comme le système
et daniel parfaitement bicaméral c'est à
dire que les lois doivent passer à la
chambre et au sénat comme titre on ne
peut pas gouverner sans aura la majorité
au sénat aussi en clair pour bien vous
comprendre c'est aussi là c'est la loi
électorale qui est en partie responsable
de cette impasse mais si y'a pas aussi
une responsabilité des chefs des
différents chefs de marty qui
visiblement de la loi électorale a été
fait par le gouvernement berlusconi et
avec surtout l'alliance et la ligue du
nord qui qui a qui avait vraiment conçu
la loi électorale pour être favori alors
nourrir en fait à la maison et surtout
surtout là où
elle a sa base électorale dans le nord
ça lui permet d'avoir une emprise sur le
sénat en fait mais c'est vrai que les
parties et italiens n'ont pas changé la
loi quand il avait la possibilité de le
faire avant les élections et c'est vrai
aussi que healy à cette protestation des
gens les gens sont c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont voté pour le moment de grillo contre
la politique la mauvaise politique le
fait que les gens sont adorables ils
sont les politiciens se sont le plus
payé d'europe et donc là il est un
polémique très forte pour baisser les
salaires des le coût de la politique et
les salaires des politiciens et donc il
y a aussi cet élément là qui est très
important ça a provoqué une situation
dans laquelle on est passé d'une
situation bipolaire bipolaire donc un
pot de centre-droite un poste de centre
gauche avec un petit centre en citations
tripolaire trois pôles qui correspond
plus ou moins à 30% de l'électorat
chacun plus un petit centre qui écrira
qui est resté jeudi est ce que est ce
que les forces de péter grillo son sont
importantes dans le pays ce qu'il faut
compter avec ce troisième homme alors en
force de beppe grillo ont été en
surprises personne ne s'attendait qu'ils
arrivent à la définir presque le
première partie ils ne sont pas les
premières parties dans la chambre des
députés
parce que le vote des électeurs à
l'étranger a été majoritairement pour le
parti démocratique donc le première
partie
si on compte les votes de l'étranger
c'est le parti démocrate mais si on ne
compte pas les veaux de l'étrangère
c'est débile et à la première dans la
chambre alors lui le problème c'est que
lui et son mouvement ne veulent pas
faire des alliances avec les autres
partis les partis traditionnels ça va se
débloquer prochainement vous pensez
alors la stratégie de bersani qui allait
charger de former le gouvernement et qui
pour l'instant est gêné parce que on est
en situation très difficile de le
président de la république ne peut pas
dissoudre les
le parlement il faut élire le nouveau
président de la république avant de
pouvoir former un gouvernement
aujourd'hui est la stratégie de bayssan
est très simple il dit moi je ne peux
pas faire une alliance avec berlusconi
parce que mon électorat ne
comprendraient pas et ça ne fonctionnait
pas de toute façon parce que les choses
que le centre gauche veut le centre
droite ne le veut pas donc ça c'est
première sur ce deuxième chose on va
essayer avec beppe grillo si beppe
grillo ne veut pas l'alliance avec nous
on ira aux prochaines élections et là on
va regagner le voit qu'on a perdus nous
le centre gauche alors que beppe grillo
m'apercevoir parce qu'il n'a pas permis
il n'aura pas permis de faire le
gouvernement
eh bien merci pour cet éclairage on
suivra cette situation merci beaucoup
alors l'europe peut-elle lutter contre
les paradis fiscaux c'est l'autre
question à la une cette semaine françois
beaudonnet en parle dans un instant avec
son invité mais d'abord direction
nicosie à chypre où la crise économique
succède à la crise bancaire reportage de
jérémie hoffmann et d'orge a beaucoup
des banquiers dans la rue la scène
aurait de quoi surprendre un français
elle a pourtant bien eu lieu en plein
centre ville de nicosie ici jusqu'à
maintenant les banques étaient toutes
puissantes
elles sont désormais dans le collimateur
de l'europe leurs syndicats crient à
l'injustice
nous ne demandons pas de faveurs
particulières on ne fait pas la manche
on demande juste à récupérer nos
économies
ce jour là ils sont plusieurs milliers
de manifestants à battre le pavé en
direction du parlement
énorme mobilisation pour ce petit pays
d'à peine 1 million d'habitants et parmi
ces banquiers en colère andré inscrit sa
fille se battre pour nos droits pour nos
emplois pour nos pensions de retraites
et pensions
ils veulent lui mais supprimée et l'une
de ses victimes anonymes du plan de
sauvetage imposées par l'europe
il dirige un service informatique de la
banque like i deuxième banque du pays
qui doit être démantelé dans les
prochaines semaines trente ans de
carrière qui s'effondre et la
perspective d'une retraite dorée qui
s'éloigne on va se retrouver sans
pension sans nourriture imaginez si vous
aviez 65 ou 70 ans vous vous retrouvez
sans argent comment faire eh bien vous
finissez à la soupe populaire
une angoisse partagée avec sa femme
ksenia elle aussi fait partie du cortège
elle aussi travail pour l'aïe qui chez
les crises à fils toute la famille est
touchée
ça va être très compliqué pour nos
enfants
il va falloir qu'il travaille pour
financer leurs études crise est synonyme
d'éclatement de la famille pourquoi nos
enfants aurait-il envie de revenir
ils n'ont plus d'avenir ici il faut bien
comprendre que c'est toute l'institution
familiale très importante ici qui va
disparaître cette colère du peuple
les parlementaires chypriote l'entendent
et la comprennent mais la nouvelle
majorité au pouvoir n'a pas vraiment eu
le choix en acceptant le plan de
sauvetage proposé par l'union européenne
nous reconnaissons que ce qui m'aide les
des milliards qui vont être accordée à
la république de chypre et en même temps
nous espérons qu'il y ait quelque chose
va ça va changer au niveau de la
gouvernance économique de les rejoindre
parce que la décision sur chypre
népalais
la première propose des problèmes après
une longue période de fermeture les
agences bancaires ont réouvert leurs
guichets quelques heures par jour avec
toujours ces mêmes files d'attentes de
chypriotes inquiets pour leurs épargnes
des banques qui représentait il y a
quelques semaines encore le poumon
économique de l'île treize mille emplois
et des actifs équivalents à 8 fois le
pib du pays
le secteur bancaire avait su attirer les
capitaux étrangers grâce à des taux
d'imposition particulièrement bas
mais andreas comme la plupart de ses
compatriotes refuse qu'on parle de
chypre comme d'un paradis fiscal
vous savez on a des règles très sévères
sur le blanchiment d'argent ici et elles
sont appliquées ce sont des accusations
injustifiées
on n'autorise pas les transactions
d'argent sale non nous ne sommes pas une
économie casino
d'ailleurs les casinos il n'y en a pas à
chypre ils sont de l'autre côté côté
turc
pour lui la crise vient d'abord de la
grèce incapable de rembourser les prêts
que lui avait accordée chypre un effet
domino qui assombrit aujourd'hui
l'avenir professionnel d'andreas
désormais le banquier envisage de
quitter son pays
seul moyen de conserver son confortable
train de vie je me tiens déjà prêts à
partir à l'étranger en ce moment j'en
vois des cv notamment dans les pays du
golfe
en europe aussi à bruxelles et à londres
son cas illustre le malaise de tout un
peuple impuissant devant sète et
financières qui commence déjà à produire
ses effets dans l'économie locale à
nicosie la principale artère commerciale
bois ce magasin fermé les uns après les
autres et tout laisse à croire que dans
les prochaines années
les chypriotes devront se serrer la
ceinture alors voilà donc pour ce
reportage à chypre signé jeremy hartmann
nous sommes sur ce plateau avec robert
goebbels bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député européen
vous êtes du groupe socialiste vous êtes
luxembourgeois on parlera d'ailleurs du
cas du luxembourg avec vous dans
quelques instants
d'abord une question sur chypre comment
est il possible selon vous qu on
découvre en tout cas que le grand public
découvre comme ça que au sein de l'union
européenne
il y avait depuis des années une place
financière offshore jeu
le grand public découvre peut-être mais
c'était quand même connu et
de rennes héritage
l'ancien empire britannique qui a cédé
sans trop chaud un peu partout quand on
voit les vrais paradis fiscaux à travers
le monde que ce soit hong kong singapour
les bahamas les virginale et puis plus
près jeu égal c'est un lot semaine tous
les sas et les fatigues de l'onf et les
six pages c'est pas choquant quand même
que déjà on est fait rentrer dans
l'union européenne dans la zone euro une
place financière offshore
le fait que la poire places financières
soient offshore n'est pas choquant en
soi si cette place financière applique
les règles des européennes elle est bon
il faut jamais oublier que dans l'union
européenne ni à la libre circulation des
capitaux ou tous commis à la libre
circulation des marchandises des
services et des hommes
c'est un des grands principes fondateurs
de l'union européenne donc le fait de
placer son argent à chypre n'a rien de
répréhensible là où ça commence à
devenir un peu plus dangereux c'est que
ceux qui ont des comptes là bas oubli de
zoom de les indiquer à leur fisc
national et le vient par mois y avait
surtout des russes c'est ça le fait que
le fait quand même qui au sein de
l'union européenne
une place qui blanchissent de l'argent
alors en provenance d'europe mais
essentiellement provenance de russie
ça ça vous choque pas écoutez je ne sais
pas s'ils ont fait du blanchiment
d'argent il existerait une très strictes
notre mois imposé par la gare fidèle au
sénat
et qui sont appliqués un peu partout en
europe en tout cas dans mon pays mais je
ne sais pas comment les autres
déchetteries ont traité tout cela
je constate simplement que maintenant
tout le monde tombe sur les pauvres et
chypriotes qui ont essentiellement perdu
leur argent en grèce parce qu'ils
avaient signé des obligations d'état
grecques et lorsque l'union européenne a
obligé tous les détenteurs d'obligations
grecques à subir un air 4 temps est
ensoleillé une collatéral
chypre a perdu beaucoup d'argent et des
banques chypriotes se sont retrouvés
avec des trous et non ça c'était cyprès
victime est une victime de cette c'était
prévisible
tout était prévisible surtout quand on
connaît la suite
c'est toujours plus facile d'expliquer
par la suite
emma je constate que par exemple
quelqu'un qui passe en argent en france
est un investisseur il ya même des
russes qui ont placé de l'argent en
france ils sont des investisseurs et
éventuellement financier des clubs
j paul ans lampre tanner sont des
investisseurs mais quand ils passent
leurs gens achètent le sens des
criminels je vois que vous voulez en
venir
on va parler dans un instant de
luxembourg il ya justement une question
d'un député chypriote revient d'entendre
et il a une question c'est même plutôt
une affirmation en ce qui concerne le
luxembourg regardez vous savez là aussi
on exagère un peu
les secteurs financière chypriote
proprement dit c'était
aux environs de 8% du pib 7,9 pour cent
au moment que luxembourg par exemple
c'est quelque chose qu'on vend pour cent
depuis le début de la crise chypriote
le luxembourg est fortement critiquée
est ce que vous êtes d'or à tort mais le
luxembourg effectivement une place
bancaire
c'est pas un paradis fiscal non du
luxembourg n'est pas un prix aucun
paradis fiscal en europe parce que la
mission se disent qu'ils sont par les
mac sont la science
effectivement il n'y a pas de paradis
fiscal les paradis fiscaux rejoindre les
sites et la chorale de l'eau est un
territoire britannique
même dans l'europe combien de ce jeu
c'est là la semaine
gibraltar tout ça c'est bête année et
puis il ya les autres à luxembourg tout
un chacun paie d'impôts que les banques
paient l'impôt est bon pétain d'impôt de
30% sur leurs gains un français qui
place son argent à luxembourg se voit
opérer une retenue à la source de 35%
sur les intérêts qu'il a gagné et sur
ces 35 % la grande ajoutée et transféré
en france office alors c'est vous savez
que l'un des éléments pour la définition
d'un paradis fiscal même s'il ya une
polémique sur qu'est-ce qu'un paradis
fiscal c'est l'opacité
pourquoi le luxembourg même si la
position est visiblement en train de
changer et il avec l'autriche l'un des
deux seuls pays d'europe qui refuse la
transmission automatique de données aux
autres pays européens
parce que nous avons toujours estimé
qu'une
contenu à la source était beaucoup plus
facile à faire et d'ailleurs la grande
majorité des pays de l'union européenne
pour les résidents nationaux
on opère une retenue à la source en
france si vous touchez des intérêts sur
votre compte on opère une note de la
ressource c'est un système beaucoup plus
facile que cette transmission tous
azimuts
même chose si non parce que 6 1 6 1 et à
demande à luxembourg des informations
sûres et zohra difficilement non non non
non il faut les chasser ce soir
chaque année il ya des centaines et des
centaines de commissions rogatoires
ils sont tous donnés par un juge
français et qui concernent des citoyens
français qui ont des pratiques
il faut faire une demande il faut faire
une demande spécifique qu'il faut dire
est ce que monsieur cahuzac à un panda
luxembourg les pour le moment là les
autres thés judiciaire faut obliger les
banques luxembourgeoises et vive
inquiétude
mais ce que nous avons toujours venus
empêcher c'est que le fisc puissent
faire une sorte pêche à la règle parce
que c'est pas parce que le secret
bancaire est quand même également une
certaine protection
imaginez que le secret bancaire n'aurait
pas prévalu en suisse dont la deuxième
guerre mondiale
toutes les parts de juifs ont été
confisqués par les nazis
est ce vraiment un conte et musique on
n'est plus là aujourd'hui si on a quand
même pas mal de dictature encore à
travers le monde et même en europe qu'il
faut chasser lorient parce que ça va
être le secret bancaire vous pouvez
protéger des dictateurs par exemple non
nous ne protégeons rien parce que
l'agent salle à luxembourg est
pourchassé il existe un rapport annuel
qui vous dit que les banques sont
obligées à le sens bourg de signaler
tout mouvement de capital suspects et
cet argent là est saisie et elle tourne
éventuellement à ceux qui devraient les
tenir ses capitaux et encore une fois
jusqu'à présent le gouvernement
luxembourgeois comme le gouvernement
autrichien comme le nouvea monstrueuse
et quelques autres ont estimé que le
secret bancaire bien agencé était une
protection pour les humbles citoyens
est ce que ce sera ma dernière question
est-ce que puisque le gouvernement
luxembourgeois a dit que les choses
étaient en train d'évoluer qu'il était
prêt à faire éventuellement des
concessions ça vous trouvez que c'est
une bonne chose ou vous ça va tuer
l'industrie de votre pays non ça ne va
certainement pas tuer l'industrie
d'entreprises de toute façon là
place financière luxembourgeoise est
devenue une place financière très
international qui fait un essentielle
ment des investissements ce qui explique
terre pourquoi effectivement le poids de
cette industrie est très important par
rapport au produit intérieur brut de mon
pays mais la situation est toute
différente de celle de chypre chypre est
avec une passe financière qui avait
augmenté au club
aussi au cours des années mais où tous
passionnants sur deux pays le luxembourg
par exemple est le plus grand
investisseur dans le roman russie
ou en amérique du sud ou en asie non
c'est une situation totalement
différente et les ceux qui investissent
sont des sociétés qui ont pignon sur rue
très bien merci beaucoup
robert goebbels on aura noté selon vous
dont il n'existe pas de paradis fiscal
en europe merci en tout cas d'avoir
accepté notre invitation c'est la fin de
cette émission on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine avec kathia gilder pour une
nouvelle émission de robes dos de d'ici
là bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires